yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing jon stewart plant Knight to c6
oh I think I think the file is good I
don't quite remember why and how it's ok
again this looks like a normal chest now
should you fall probably no fire well
that would take but with the knight on
c6 this is making a bit more sense than
some other cases yeah if i take now only
five it's going to be very dull i was
thinking this anyway night only five
does not necessarily have to be well
placed let's see what he does p 6 yeah I
wonder at four is good him I didn't like
it to be honest the weakening f1 so I'm
going to wait here for a moment until I
decide what to do yeah and this is what
I expected and I wasn't quite sure what
to do against it probably going back on
b3 the light is also not doing much
jump like it okay I didn't do this too
well so what's the deal here he wants to
play it to c6 I guess well I can take
him and try to play form an advantage on
the light squares on d5 the should be
fine we can maybe very plain night Xu
form we should be 793 5891 and there
should be some think that should be good
for mind okay so yeah here I was
thinking I take and now Bishop up to see
form so that i can try to trade it on d5
and that looks active but now I'm
threatening look to your one winning the
Queen and he's just as bad very quickly
played yeah what is best here
yeah I think it'd be shifted 5c more or
less has to take the night eggs and
quite skeptical about twin takes be too
he still play that without much thinking
so would be one queen bee swarm oh can I
somehow trap this Queen don't say it at
the moment I have a couple of good
positions that i can lead but I don't
see a win which is quite sad it always
has he fought to go to I can also not
covered before at the moment let's add
quite sad what why wasn't windy for
working I didn't see how I trap the
Queen which is probably my own in
competence but set it free it maybe he
saw something that I didn't seem
remarkable if I would have known that he
would just give the quick help lift
plate look db1 a little bit quicker
[Music]
and yeah let's not get back regulated
check
yeah well clean up is quite okay so
what's easiest in from the jacks you can
[Music]
check check check check late I actually
thought credentialing anyway and yeah
there are the mysterious mysterious game
there I mean I think I'm like it's
completely fine yup lost some time you
with my maneuvers and it didn't really
net much uhm Jung can switch that on the
engine wants to play Bishop f4 that
makes sense okay I will choke and light
takes you for something to check with
this this is actually the easiest em
who's hanging with seeing something else
so that's easier okay bishop here and
now I just wanted to play for that week
square now I have two minor pieces
looking at the square on d5 and he has
only the bishop 16 to cover 24 is not a
good idea am I think because after
Queenie to as the engine indicates you
have to go back it's just like you have
to go back he played b5 and when 255
takes six
here and and now I don't trap the Queen
right now the engine also doesn't see so
much exactly this is the thing I play
here he has to go to deform and he
always has the c-4 square M that is not
all that clear in the game our sir
thinking maybe c3 Queen here and now I
wasn't sure the engine indicates Queen
g-form that's an interesting move
threatening Knight f6 I was also
thinking that maybe I have a slight
advantage in hoops in this position this
this may be here and then cover it like
like this the idea is king king up to e2
and push the rook back or trade books if
i can trade rooks here i'm a lot better
with the bad pawn structure that black
ass but black is active here as we see
here also with the end and evaluation so
Queen g4 is better but there was
absolutely no need to give the Queen and
I mean he may be overlooked at CC form
and after that a cam Queen up hmm bit
strange them I also quickly and like to
change something in the opening here is
5 yeah I don't know maybe just d5 but
that doesn't feel too convincing either
maybe it's it's best to actually
transpose into to an old we line since
the rule no pestilence maybe this is
right I'm not quite sure here this
didn't feel so bad for black and maybe
94 is wrong and actually just this this
is interesting if your eggs maybe take
with the pawns then we'll keep one
Bishop f4 22 now something like that for
me I had absolutely nothing I thing out
of the opening ok guys thanks for
watching